well the summer travel season is in full
effect and vacationers aren't wasting
any time just released numbers from
harry reid international show june was
its busiest month ever that's right but
today some other numbers are in the
headlines our airport made a list
because of its high rate of flight
delays and cancellations
travel at harry reid international is
thriving and this california couple is
glad to be back in las vegas so usher is
the main reason why we're here but as
the summer travel season is underway so
are the headaches for many of these
passengers when we landed and we got to
the gate the bridge was stuck or
something and we had to
wait flight tracking site flightaware
releasing data showing airports
cancellations and delays where harry
reid international had 29 percent of
their total flights delayed and more
than 350 cancellations between june 1st
and july 24th not as high as the first
week of the year where staffing and
covet 19 were to blame delays can be for
so many different reasons whether it's
weather
you know staffing issues mechanical
issues topping their u.s list for
scheduled flights canceled newark
laguardia and washington's national
airport southwest airlines telling us
operational performance has improved
across the board
more than 92 percent of their flights
arrived within one hour of their
scheduled time between june and july 4
of this year airport officials say june
was also their busiest time in airport
history 4.6 million passengers almost
4.7
you know las vegas continues to be a
popular destination for these travelers
their delay was less than an hour but
they say las vegas is always worth the
wait there's not much you can do i mean
that's kind of the thing with flying is
there's delays or there's things that
mishaps that happen and you just kind of
have to roll with punches
rolling with the punches and a lot of
patience all right airport officials say
if you are planning to travel check your
flight status prior to arriving at the
airport also those texts and email
alerts from the airlines can be very
useful